hey guys and welcome to the Sony film
simulation Community this will be a
in-depth tutorial on how to use Sony
film simulations how to expose them how
to use the temperature in the color
filter to achieve different film locks
and overall I just want to show you how
to get better color out of the Sony
system only using the picture profile
menu because it's a really powerful menu
which after you learn the specifics of
it you'll understand how many
possibilities they open up for you if
you're not familiar with Sony film
simulation recipes uh it's a personal
project that I've been working on for
the past two years and they are
customized picture profile settings that
are meant to give you better color out
of your camera for both uh video mode
and photo mode you can find all Sony
film solution recipes on my website link
description down below
so I want to show you how to set up the
picture profiles inside the camera but
before that I want you to search if your
camera model is compatible with the
picture profiles more exactly if it has
picture profiles because most Hybrid
models have it
but the for example the a7r and the A9
does not have this function or feature
because these camera models are more
focused on the photo mode no video mode
so the thing with Sony film simulations
is you're based off the picture profile
menu which was initially meant only for
video but Sony enables us to use it for
the photo mode as well as long as we
shoot
raw plus JPEG and this only film
submission recipes will be embedded into
the jpeg
so as long as you should drop the jpeg
you will be able to use them for both
video and photos this will help people
to cut down the editing process in most
cases
and just enhance the experience of
shooting with the camera in the moment
also using Sony film Solutions it just
enhances your experience while
in a photo shoot or video shoot when you
show your model how the footage look
like straight out of camera is just a
much nicer experience to have great
colors on the back of the screen and
when you transfer them on your computer
to be able to use them as a reference so
people don't think like you know all the
colors are yucky and you're the
photographer so they can associate those
colors with you so it's just really
important to get great colors out of the
camera even if you added 14-bit raw
files
if you want to hear a little bit of a
backstory on how I started this project
uh it will be a pretty long video then
just you know let it roll if not then I
prepared chapters so you can find the
information that you're looking for in
the timeline down below so go ahead and
just you know look for the information
that is most is of most interest for you
so how all this started is that about
two years ago Fuji announced their field
simulation cameras and recipes and
everything and I was super excited about
that because I you know I really love
analog and shooting film and the idea of
getting great pictures and analog like
colors out of the camera that really got
me excited because you know just
enhanced this experience of you know if
you shoot like street photography or
whatever you just happily like quirky
cool interesting colors that I can like
wow you know it just makes you feel
inspired and keeps you get going it
keeps you going you know and
about years ago in January in 2020 I
think I tested the Fuji which has a lot
of you know one of my favorites which is
a classic neck which is probably one of
the best film solutions from Fuji uh
subjectively subjectively speaking but
the idea is I was kind of disappointed
when I actually tested the camera
because
what I felt is that the film simulations
work more are affecting or working more
on saturation and contrast just like
regular picture profiles like let's say
Vivid portrait nature nighttime you know
like with picture profiles which any
camera has like Nikon Canon you know
even Sony and it felt like while dialing
in different film film
recipes it felt like they're working
more on the only difference between them
was the saturation and the contrast so I
felt like hey I can create this kind of
stuff in inside Sony because I already
started working with the picture profile
menu and I knew it had so many color
modes and so many uh like options and
features on adjusting contrast colors
you know very in-depth and I said okay
let me try create let me try to create a
couple film simulations for Sony cameras
and uh the addition was to create them
for myself so I can cut down the editing
process and the color correction because
I also felt like Sony colors are not bad
but they're not great either they're
kind of like you know meh like okay it's
there in a way they're very accurate I
would say sometimes they're kind of
yucky but in most of the cases I feel
like they're a little bit too accurate
in real life
and accurate colors I know I don't know
if you noticed but actual accurate
colors are not always the most uh
Pleasant colors they're not the colors
that we want to see or we enjoy to see
so I just wanted to create a couple
picture profiles that I can use for
photos and videos I noticed I can you
know use the picture profiles for photos
as well and they will be embedded in the
JPEG and that you know kind of start to
save me a lot of time and got me excited
okay I can create a picture profiles
that will actually cut down the editing
process in situations but I don't want
to edit the pictures
um
seven months later uh I came up with uh
eight picture profiles and they came out
so good that I decided I want to share
them with everybody else for free and I
started making a video for it which took
me about five months to create uh it's
one of my best videos and it kind of
like skyrocketed after I posted it uh
one year ago
and uh you know like that was when
everything started like people asked me
if I can copy uh the classic Chrome
Dakota Chrome 64 from Fuji the Fuji
Eterna and honestly I didn't know if I
can do this because
um even though you had so many options
inside the camera and you can achieve so
you know so many looks with the picture
profiles
copying an exact look of a camera seemed
pretty impossible because you need more
refined adjustments and tools like you
would find in DaVinci Resolve color
creating a tab or Premiere Pro or Final
Cut you know like individual color
Channel Hue saturation Luma uh
customization so I
I didn't know if I can create if I can
copy those uh film simulations but I
tried anyways and in the end I I found
out that
um I could copy you know like multiple
film solutions from Fuji cameras and
actually I had so much control inside
the picture profile menu I copied the
fujiterna it's a high fidelity copy I
have a low Fidelity copy which is for
people who don't have a hero G gamma and
I have a high fidelity copy for those
who have a hiloji gamma and I would say
it's about 90 to 95 percent accurate to
the Fujifilm after I've I also made a
comparison test you can go to my channel
and check it out
um I copy the classic Chrome I
I tried to copy the Kodachrome but I I
mean I didn't try to copy after I
checked the code Chrome 64 from Fuji I
felt and after I I made some research on
how the Kodachrome 64 looked like back
in the day because now it discontinued I
felt like the Fuji wasn't really trying
to or wasn't replicating the look of the
chronochrome 64 so I just went on a
different path and made a Sony film
simulation that actually tried to
replicate and emulate the colors and the
feeling of the original Kodachrome 64.
so the idea is I I copied a couple
picture profiles from Fuji with really
high fidelity and you know color
accuracy accuracy and besides that I
created a total uh 32 Sony film
simulations uh in one year so in two
weeks gonna be one year since the
original Sony film solution video I will
put the link up here if you want to
watch it for later and
um you know I really do appreciate all
your support and uh this was a really
interesting project and it's still an
interesting project because I will keep
on working on them and I keep on
updating the profiles every month or
every couple of months
to ensure uh better color Renditions and
a better color Fidelity for each profile
um so that is the story hopefully it was
not boring for you guys it's it's a bit
long
um but I try to shorten it as much as
possible uh this is the first time I'm
actually talking Off Script so I might
be you know
blabbering a lot uh hopefully it's not
too boring
but I I said okay I need to get used to
because I wrote a script which is like
10 pages and I was like okay I can't
learn this I can memorize this because
it's just too much so I gotta try to
speak free flow
so when shooting Sony film simulations I
usually shoot Roblox jpeg as I mentioned
and that's because film skill missions
will be baked in the JPEG but not in the
Raw most of the times I will use the
jpeg straight out the camera unless I
have a really good shot that I want to
print or use in my portfolio in which
case I will take the extra time and the
extra hours to edit it and Capture One
because you know I want to ensure
everything it looks exactly how I want
it to look like and of course in Capture
One or in any video or photo editing
software you have more control that in
camera
uh we'll talk about this later in the
video as well what I would like to see
in newer Sony models but of course you
have more uh features more tools and I
can finally adjust each color and sit
you know multiple hours to edit a single
shot to make it look as perfect as
possible because I'm also a
perfectionist and sometimes when I print
something I want it to look as good as
possible so yeah I will use the 14-bit
raw footage because of course it has an
advantage to JPEG files but you know if
you shoot every day uh 500 1000 pictures
it will take a lot of time to edit all
those shots and you know it's just
useful to have great colors out of the
camera and just use the jpegs so I don't
spend four hours editing all those shots
which could be done from inside the
camera
so how to access the picture profile
menu so this may differ from One camera
model to another but most of the times
uh Sony cameras have a button right next
to the shutter button which is a custom
bottom maybe custom one or custom two
and that button is assigned to the
picture profile menu but again you need
to check if your camera is compatible
with the picture profiles if it has it
this may differ from from One camera to
another if you don't have it assigned to
that button uh then you'll have to
search in the inner menu to access it
you can assign the picture profile menu
to one of your many custom buttons for
faster access and I highly recommend
that because it really does save you a
lot of time and helps you with the
creative flow whilst in the middle of a
photo or video shoot so after you have
found the picture profile menu let's
enter it by hitting right on the dial
wheel and now that you're in the picture
profile menu you can either have 10 or
11 open slots where you can add your own
custom film simulation settings and save
them as they are
unfortunately we cannot name them for
better recognition like Fuji and that's
one of the things that I would like to
see in future models I would like to be
able to name my picture profiles and not
only for film simulations but because
they are 11 open slots like open picture
profiles and I cannot remember all of
them like what picture profile I have at
slot 1 or slot 2. you know like maybe uh
if I haven't used this camera in a long
time maybe I forgot what I put in the
first lot or the second one and I just
want to be able to name them you like
this is an old Porsche 800 or maybe this
is a slog 2 s log 3 this is CD4 whatever
you know I would just like to be able to
customize that so I can easily identify
each profile because right now what I
have to do to check what what gamma what
settings I've used what picture profile
what film simulation this is is that to
get inside each picture profile and
check what settings I have so that again
is complicated because as F2 profiles
are very similar then I'll I will lose
time or get confused and maybe just
shoot with the wrong profile because I
just you know didn't have the time to
really check what settings I had so this
is one thing that I would like to see in
the future models and another thing that
I would like to see is at the moment we
cannot save a preset color for a preset
color temperature for each individual
picture profile so you will need to set
a different color settings each time you
change the film simulation because each
has a slightly different color setting
this is not a deal breaker because
either way when you shoot with film
summations you will change your
temperature according you to your uh
scene and according to the lighting that
you have in the room or outside you know
but you know it would be nice to be able
to save uh if you're the type of person
that shoots only with a custom setting
temperature with uh individual picture
profile it will be nice to be able to
save that so you just dial in and it's
ready to go you know one thing that I
would love to see in the future is maybe
a new Sony line I love to see a camera
that focuses more on analog Aesthetics
design and feeling you know like the
feeling of the camera a camera line that
is for the artistic people the creative
Community giving the cameras a film-like
design and features like I said features
like naming the film simulations I want
I also want cool control over the
individual color channels including the
Hue saturation Luma and to be able to do
this in camera to be able to create more
in their profiles and enables on users
to get even better colors straight out
of the camera maybe they can call the
a7f or something like that let us know
in the comments what do you think about
this idea and how you would name this
camera line if it's possible maybe in
time if the community gets big enough
they will see the value around it and
create a camera model that suits our
needs so to enter any picture profile
and adjust it hit right on the dial
wheel or with the help of the joystick
and here you'll have all the options
laid out and all you have to do is just
introduce all settings as presented on
the website and remember you can go back
and forth in the menu just by hitting
right on the dial wheel and by pressing
and no by pressing the menu button on
the back of your camera to go back on
page if that made sense am I saying this
properly like you understand what I'm
talking about
so to enter any Sub menu of the picture
profile just hit right and if you want
to go back one page then hit the menu
button on the back of your camera
finally it made sense
I gotta sit straight okay so after I've
finished introducing the settings for a
favorite film simulation let's get on
with exposure and color
so what is important when shooting film
simulations okay first of all exposure
how do you expose is very important to
get a film like color out of the box the
human eye is attracted to areas with
most saturation contrast and brightness
that's why exposure and light in general
comes before color because you can have
a scene with beautiful colors but if
it's shot in a dual flat cloudy day then
it won't look as good as it could have
in the right conditions and second most
important is temperature and color
filter I'll show you how to use the
Kelvin and color filter settings to
enhance or focus more on different Hues
of the color spectrum I've already
posted multiple sample settings for each
film simulation on the website to help
you get it started so go check them out
link description down below but in order
to understand how to achieve our desired
color let me explain and understand a
couple color grading techniques and I
will explain that later in the video so
this is the basic structure of today's
video so let me show you some practical
examples for the first part of the video
I'll use the cine Chrome film
simulations because it has really nice
colors and a high dynamic range and
later on I will create a purposefully
flawed profile with bad colors so I can
show you exactly how I would correct
them inside the camera let's start with
exposure exposure is a relative thing to
talk about if I can say that because
everybody will have a different
perspective and different opinion on how
you need to expose to get a good image
but finally what I think is most
important
is to expose in such a way that it
conveys the message and the story so for
example a really popular Blockbuster is
Batman and I'm given this example
because most of you will know what I'm
talking about and if you've noticed the
last couple films all are getting darker
and darker and some people might say
that you know bad Batman is a very dark
movie
it's underexposed it's not correctly
exposed like correctly exposed but I
think exposure in this case is matching
and conveys the story really well
because it's a really dark story about
somebody that's you know fighting crime
and he's in Gotham City which is a very
dirty City will filled with you know
criminals and all that all that [ __ ] I
want to say and all that stuff
so in this particular context I think uh
the exposure is spot on because you're
trying to show how dark everything is a
world of Batman is filled with
depression with sadness with you know
like struggle and you know just
hardships so just imagine how it will
look like if you would overexpose by
once the Opera two stops making it like
super bright you know soft contrast
super high dynamic range and it will
look very dreamy uh you can include a
couple scenes into Batman where
everything is super bright you know like
memories of his parents and everything
but besides that I I I think it would be
a mistake to overexpose the scenes
because it's not convincing the message
and the vision of the story
in comparison if you do corporate work
or you know like food products stuff
like that there you have to be very
accurate okay you have to expose
properly and maybe you have to
overexpose by half a stop one stop
because the main goal of that video is
to be to reach as many people and to be
as friendly as possible to be open you
know to be attractive so when you do
your corporate job when you do a product
a food a commercial you're trying to
make that product or that person as
attractive as possible so what you will
do is make an image that is in general
most attractive to most people like the
big masses and what the big masses want
is a bright image a friendly image with
poppy colors Pleasant colors so you'll
try to make something that is not too
crazy something that is widely accepted
and in that case I think it would be
suited to Overexposed by Maybe One Stop
two stops to make the image a little bit
brighter you know soft uh contrast and
just to make it look little bit more
pleasing you know as a conclusion what I
feel is important is that each element
of your cinematography can raise the
message or the mood of your vision so
it's all a matter of message and context
what do you want to show what emotions
you want to reveal and how you want the
viewer to feel like related to your
subject just like color grading exposure
has its influences story or the mood
you're trying to convey a general rule
of thumb I can give you which will work
in most situations is to expose for the
subject and the viewer eyes will follow
as I mentioned previously the human eye
is most attracted to the brightest most
vibrant and consciously part of the
image so hide what is Irrelevant in the
shadows because you don't want anything
distracting the viewer from the subject
expose for areas where you want people
to look at like the subject like the
person the building whatever you know
you need to properly expose that and
blowout highlights if they are
distracting the viewer from the subject
this is a very general rule the rest is
a matter of taste and personal style
take that with a grain with a grain of
salt
that's how they say it when showing your
work on the internet there will be a lot
of critics like people that will tell
you like you didn't expose correctly you
exposed over you're underexposed and
stuff like that and there will be many
people that have no artistic taste so if
you have a different style which is not
very uh popular or you know not very
accepted people will keep on
we'll try to bring you down like you
know with meaningful comments like oh
we'll try to bring you down with uh
hateful comments like this is [ __ ] like
you don't know what you're doing like
this is underexposed like whatever you
know Overexposed in the end uh I suggest
you remain open to perspectives and
criticism so you can learn more and just
uh you know notice what you can improve
through your photography but at the same
time uh understand that maybe you have a
different style from others and maybe a
new style that is still not uh
uh widely accepted or popular and people
need to get used to it or people just
don't like it because they most people
most people
are you know playing safe and any
anything they do they try to play safe
because maybe they don't have a vision
and that's what I meant like some people
don't have the artistic Vision they
cannot see what you see so
um keep that in mind most people might
find comfort in shooting safe because
everybody will approve they have made a
good photograph and that is fine but you
don't have to take the same boring path
so the decision the choice is yours one
more thing worth mentioning when it
comes to exposure on Sony cameras be
aware of your camera's screen brightness
because I notice when my brightness is
set to plus two which is the maximum my
footage on the back of my camera will
look much brighter than it is in reality
so always check the histogram and the
light meter to see if what you see on
the back of your camera is what you will
get on your computer
I would love if Sony would put better
screens on their cameras because they're
leading in technology and they you know
they have really good TVs and screens in
general so I don't really get it why
they put these crappy screens which are
not very accurate on their mirrors
cameras probably to cut down a cost but
I rather you know like pay 100 euro more
or I don't know even 200 euro more on
Emily's camera and to get a good screen
because that is very very important
since it's not a cinema camera in many
occasions you will use this camera
without an external monitor which has
accurate colors and all kind of
different tools to measure exposures so
the
so yeah I you know I just wish a newer
and future Sony models a better screen
so I can get accurate exposure and so I
can uh you know
work with the screen and not against it
uh now that we have cleared a basic
understanding of exposure let's get into
color
so I made a couple color settings for
each picture profile and you can find
them all my website uh as a basic on the
website you will find a Kelvin value
like -1000 Kelvin and the color filter
setting uh to emphasize even more on
different Hues and that will look like
let's say A1 G1 so what does shooting
1000 Kelvin below uh normal temperature
look like well for example if you are if
daytime you should usually sorry for
that so if daytime usually you shoot
5500 Kelvin which is you know like
correct white balance with this profile
rated at minus 1000 Kelvin below normal
temperature you will actually Shoot 4
500 Kelvin and then you apply the color
filter settings that it follows which
will be A1 G1 in this scenario so for
that understanding on how Color Works I
want to categorize color into two major
groups which is warm tones and cold
tones this will great please simplify
how we see color and make everything
logical and have more sense when using
the color settings to push the color
spectrum in the right direction next we
need to understand how pushing
temperature and the color filter in
different direction will change color
Hues and emphasize on different tones
okay so remember what I mentioned about
sectioning colors into two major groups
think about that and don't worry about
the rest for the moment I will reveal
everything during the video so you can
watch it as many times as you need to as
a first you need to decide if you want a
warmer or a colder image based on that
you can gently start with minor
adjustments lowering the temperature by
let's say minus 500 Kelvin if you're
more courageous you can come with me and
lower it down to -2000 Kelvin below
normal so again what does normal
temperature mean
simple answer is correct white balance
so if you're not sure what is correct
white balance in a scene you can go into
the temperature menu and down the list
will be custom menu setup or custom
setup menu where you can let the camera
decide for yourself what is the correct
white balance in the scene with the help
of a gray card of course so if you don't
have a great card don't worry you can
point at anything that should be gray in
the real world and use that as a calorie
reference I have an application
installed on my phone which is very
helpful and it's called flashlight
which enables me to use custom colors on
the screen and that is very helpful in
getting a custom color preset like a
gray card and also for for photo shoots
when I don't care with me lights and I
just want to quickly color paint the
background or the model after created
the custom white balance settings you
can save it as a preset you have three
slots open so to save it as a preset you
have to hit the OK button in the middle
or if you just want to use it as a
reference all you have to do to cancel
the setting is press the menu button so
one important thing to remember because
this is very helpful in many situations
by using this function the camera will
try to balance out colors in the scene
by overcompensating the complementary
color so let's say you put an orange
card in front of your camera and you hit
OK the camera will try to overcompensate
the scene the orange predominance in the
scene by pushing a lot of teal in in the
color spectrum so then you can save it
and use that as a cine Steel film
simulation preset and you will get
really nice cold tones over the over the
image if you just started with Sony film
simulations or if you're just unsure of
what colors you want in your scene maybe
start by dialing in from the minimum
Kelvin to the highest and to see how the
colors are being influenced and which
color tones look more pleasing to you
okay so now that we have an image with
predominant colors what is next and how
will this help me in achieving the look
that I want well that's simple let me
explain this in DaVinci so I can show
exactly
on so I have this clip into Da Vinci and
as I drag down the temperature you can
see what is going on in the color warper
you can see how each Hue is Shifting
towards a cooler tone red has become a
pink and green shift towards cyan
so you're actually shifting cues in a
different direction and you can correct
skin tones just by playing with the
color temperature but this needs to be
subtle but the skin tone is too green or
yellow drag the temperature down by 500
to 1000 Kelvin and you will notice how
it will correct the skin tones shifting
them a little bit towards pink making it
look a little bit more pleasant you can
do that further with the help of the
color filter by pushing it towards blue
magenta this will shift all the colors
including the greens making it look more
cyan and even more pleasing
so when creating color presets for Sony
film simulations you need to take into
consideration what colors you have
present in the scene and where you want
to bring the whole color spectrum of the
image to balance it accordingly now let
me show you how to correct the picture
profile inside the camera I prepared a
purposefully flawed profile with bad
colors so I can show exactly how I
correct it let's check it out
after a quick analysis I noticed the
whole image is predominantly green and
magenta so there are a couple things you
can do and I will start with correcting
the yellows first raise the color face
to shoot Hues this will make the greens
a little bit more yellow the Reds more
magenta and the blue is more teal and
let's reduce saturation for acceptable
look
now let's finally adjust the exposure
with the help of the ND filter
[Music]
to warm up the image while keeping a
little bit of the blue magents and the
Shadows so one way of doing this is by
bringing down the color filter to Blue
magenta but that will make my image even
cooler so I need to counterbalance the
overall temperature of the image with
the Kelvin settings so what I want to do
is make sure the Kelvin is a little bit
higher than I normally wanted to and
then apply the color filter settings to
Blue magenta
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay it's already looking great I just
want to reduce the saturation even more
to emphasize on a more nostalgic kind of
a look and change the color space from
BT 2020 to rec 709 so it renders more
accurate greens and Blues
let's check the before and after
this is only one way it can go when
correcting or creating picture profiles
there's so many color variations that
can be created it's only about
understanding how each color influences
one another if you want a more in-depth
video on how to create picture profiles
let me know in the comments this is a
very basic example which hopefully helps
you understand the logic and the power
of the picture profile menu but we
didn't even talk about the color
differences of each color mode
differences in Gammas how it can
influence the Shadows with the black
point and black ammo settings or the
color depth menu
thank
you
there's a lot to be said about this menu
and there's a lot of color theory going
on behind which is helping me create
these Sony film simulations if you also
like to learn more about color theory or
color grading you can book a color
grading course with me or just use the
settings provided in the Sony film
simulation plan if you just want great
colors without any hassle maybe in the
same time pay attention how these
settings will influence the other colors
in the scene to make sure everything
falls right into place okay different
scenario let's say your Blues are too
magenta uh inside the picture profile
menu bring up the color face to plus
four now the blues will be corrected but
the skin tones might be a little bit too
pink go into the color menu and set the
temperature by 200 to 500 Kelvin higher
and in the color filter bring it up
towards Amber and green just bad tab
let's say A1 G1 by adding Amber and
green to the scene you brought the skin
tones a little bit more towards orange
and the blues more towards green so you
fix two problems out of one shot my
recommendation is to Start Gentle and in
time in camera color grading will become
second nature nowadays I set the
temperature and the color filter right
on the spot from the top of my head and
I always analyze the colors present in
the scene and edit the film simulations
depending on how I would like them to
look like to be mentioned that for color
accuracy when using some film
simulations like Kodachrome 64 we need
to respect the dedicated settings to
emulate the accurate colors of the film
stock meaning if you want to get
Kodachrome 64 to look like the real deal
I recommend trying out the settings on
the website if accuracy is not that
important and you want to experiment
with different Hues but you will like
the base contrast and colors of
Kodachrome 64 then you are free to do so
nobody's stopping you I recommend
playing around with these settings and
color filters to understand how it
affects your color in the scene and so
you can create new picture profiles
which you can share with others one more
thing I want to mention is that on the
website we have a forum where you can
ask any kind of questions about Sony
film simulations you can post your own
recipes your own work or just connect
with other members passionate about film
look analog colors and such you can find
all film Solutions and color settings on
my website link description down below
so this is pretty much all I wanted to
show you when it comes to Sony film
simulations uh how to use them how to
expose them what does the color filter
settings mean or how to use the
temperature to influence the overall
tone of the image hopefully this cleared
up some questions and makes it easier
for you to the Sony film solution
settings let us know in the comments if
you have any other questions or what do
you think about the new Sony analog line
do you think this is possible
what features would you like to see in
it and how would you name it let us know
what you think about it this idea and
thanks for watching until next time take
care and remember have fun see ya